today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza 18:11
Pico Boulevard on the way to the beach
great block pizza
today's guest is is a Louisianna a
fellow Louisiana and a young man that
I'm a huge fan of a man that's you know
has constantly risen against adversity
uphill towards towards a single goal
he's a UFC champion in many people's
eyes and a title contender right now I
am happy to have mr. Dustin Poirier
[Music]
yeah my I'm from Covington in Toronto
okay I think that's between Louisiana
and Mississippi no Allen yeah there's a
kitten towards Alabama like off off i-10
if you're heading towards like you know
if you pass like I ten hits like a
Jackson exit yeah and then but I think
that's high 55 and then if you keep
going down they're closer like Abita
Springs and yeah right next would be a
spring yeah yeah did we lose huh good
beers out there no good beers dude dude
Abita Springs has this place here where
it's like for dead man's curves like all
come together at once and it's literally
like there's a grave you're like so many
people have died there like it's the
absolute worst idea sounds horrible yeah
there we go right there so what town are
you from Louisiana I'm from Lafayette oh
really oh there that red that is God's
country yeah is it really better believe
it yeah yeah so do you miss being at
home cuz now you live in Florida no I
moved to Florida in 2012 yeah when I
first made the switch to American Top
Team right and then uh you know I bought
a house there me and my wife lived there
for five years maybe almost and then we
had a daughter so I sold my house and
moved back I live in Louisiana oh you do
oh yeah oh really
yeah oh that's awesome I just go to
South Florida when I do training camp so
I'll go there eight to ten weeks yeah
yeah I have an apartment there yeah but
my home is in Louisiana so are there
other fighters that are down there in
South Florida like that you get to see
when you go there like is like what is
that training camp vibe life training
camp is correct well first of all
American Top Team is just a mecca of not
only mixed martial artist but boxers
come in and out kick boxers jiu-jitsu
practitioners I mean you it's just
combat sports headquarters from people
from all over the world so there's a few
guys in the stable that live there yeah
but there's a lot of people that it's
rotating I mean there's new new people
in and out so I always have different
training partners when I'm there yeah
you know lots of guys from like Russia
come in we have a lot of guys in that
pfl tournament right now so a lot of
Russian guys in right now do the rush
and something-something what is wrong
with Russian people missiles were
different about a mom I don't know man
they're hairy for sure yeah Russian
people dude I dated this Russian girl
for a while broke she was crazy
she was always trying to do like but
stuff to me stuff she was something's
wrong with her
to me like she was not you yeah I know
she was wild so when you're in those
like these training camps of our people
do you are you just training with dudes
all day like is there just constant
access to different types of like you
know like if you wanted to do like bo
staff fighting or you know do anything
yeah anything no I mean they probably
have some self-defense stuff that they
do teach but it's it's normal stuff they
have boxing classes jujitsu classes
mixed martial arts classes but then
there's a pro team and I have our own
separate schedule so we don't for the
most part the pro guys don't train on
the normal everyday you know schedule
that the customer or a family would come
in you know ya can't have guys in there
oh I see you're saying beating each
other up but their shirts off sweating
and grinding all over with kids on the
mat hey you guys will get bloody in
there
it you know it's sparring sometimes gets
pretty serious now yeah that's a
question I have because like I'm not a
fighter dude like I'm not even I don't
even think I could really defend myself
you know like I would if I had a shield
I could but I don't think if I had like
just my own body I could you know so
when I see people fighting I'm like damn
this [ __ ] is wild bruh you know do you
when you guys are doing the practice
fighting the training how-how-how actual
is that to what we see when we're
watching the cage you know younger guys
for sure it's pretty close to what you
see in the cage because these guys are
nuts they're trying to find out if they
still if they are fighters they're
running out there they're soul searching
themselves but guys who have a lot of
fights you know we kind of trained smart
and keep it under control for the most
part the grappling and wrestling and
stuff is live as hard as it goes you
know like it would be a real scramble in
a fight right with the grappling and
submissions and stuff like that but when
it comes to the kickboxing and boxing
and stuff there are moments where it
gets heated but most of the time it's
pretty under control yeah yeah so so
right now you're down in Florida and
your family's in Louisiana no so when I
go to Florida I'm back in Louisiana now
okay when I go to Florida my family
comes with me because I'm there eight or
ten weeks you know I fly my wife and
daughter out right because I just can't
stay away from my family man you know
yeah I love my girls and and I need them
with me especially going through
training camp
yeah but uh yeah I was supposed to find
ideas November third in Madison Square
Garden Joe Rogan dude I'm tall Joe one
time and and we're talking about
something and I told him I was like dude
I'm of Dustin Poirier fan he's from the
same state as me and he goes do you want
to go to the Poirier Diaz fight and I
was like oh my god I was so excited but
I had to work that night in Buffalo but
you guys got so what happened you're my
my hip is pretty jacked up that's why
I'm out here in LA yeah I'll be here
until Wednesday I'm having some stem
cells and synovial fluid injections in
my hip joint on Wednesday morning right
so that should be ease the pain a little
bit I have two tears in my labrum uh-huh
and because of that it's causing some
bone-on-bone and it's just really
painful man is it yeah anytime I get
stretched out or overextended in a
stride or I I just pay for it really bad
so like where do you pay for it in the
muscle or where the muscle hits the
block in an actual joint where the where
the the top of your bone goes in you
know the ball and socket joint where
your where your hip bones meet yeah
because a lot of feels to get those
replaced sometimes as they get older
yeah I mean I gotta try to take best
care of it so that doesn't happen
are you worried about like like is that
like a bigger worry than just having to
step out of this fight um you know
honestly talking to the doctors they
think surgery is gonna be like
inevitable sooner we were gonna hats
gonna have to happen but this will buy
me a few camps this stem cell and stuff
yeah and let me do do my training a
little bit painful you know less pain
but uh do not just if if it'll last me
into the World Championship then I'm
golden yeah that's all I wanted to want
to be the world champion then you can
cut my hips off you can like get Tommy
to escape for you yeah is that this so
like I would say I was actually talking
to a friend of mine I called a friend of
mine today who lives down in a new
iberia actually on the way up here I was
just you know it's how you were coming
and I was like hey man I got Dustin
Poirier coming in today and and we were
just talking about like well I wonder
what drives like a fighter at a certain
point and do you think that the drive to
fight has been different from when you
started to where your to what your kind
of drive is now does it evolve because I
can imagine as you get old like as you
get older like you know when you're
young you're kind of like had that
frenetic youthful energy and when you're
an adult it's you get a little bit more
articulate
- like what your plan is has any of you
noticed any that in yourself first sure
man that's uh definitely a lot of a lot
changes I had my first mixed martial
arts fight when I was 18 years old yeah
you know I'm 29 now so 11 years later
you know I still have love for the fight
but it's just I'm fighting for different
reasons you know I've found out that the
first reasons I was fighting for I've
discovered those things and found out
more about myself and and now I'm here
you know you mature and grow in the
sport and as a person and I'm a father
and a husband and stuff things change in
your life right fighting still fighting
but uh yeah I'm fighting for different
reasons now you know I got people
depending on me that's the biggest
motivation I could ever ever have is it
really yeah yeah oh yeah so you feel
that like that now you now it's like
yeah I wonder sometimes I guess what you
have to evolve for different like not
passions but different things that drive
you yeah and uh like I said man I got
mouths to feed and I'm trying to leave a
legacy I'm at a point in my career where
the next moves are is is huge you know
yeah yeah yeah do you think yes you
start thinking about like you know
Michael by spring he's does a um you
know he does actually I was watching an
interview you did with him the other day
which was pretty funny it was after one
of your fights yeah and he's like you
know he's works with Fox now and does
fights if I get do you think about that
kind of stuff or do you think about like
would you like to train maybe in the
future like train younger guys or do you
have that some of those thoughts yeah
I'm gonna be in fighting some some way
or another but like yeah I mean I am
this this is what I am but um
everything I ever everything I have in
my life you do that everything I have is
from from these two things right here in
my brain you feel me I didn't finish
high school I had you know low paying
jobs you know and and now everything I
have is an empire built off of fighting
and chasing my dream so I can't turn my
back on this I'll never I'll always be
part of fighting somehow yeah training
people is not a huge passion of mine but
being part of the sport is like helping
professional fighters it's something
that I would like to do like training
families and kids and stuff it's in
jiu-jitsu I'll have a lot of buddies who
open gyms and that's what they do now
and right that's not a big passion of
mine but you know another five six seven
years we'll see maybe there will be but
right now it's just I'm addicted to the
fight yeah yeah so D so dude so how were
you
like I mean were you just devastated
when you realize that you couldn't go on
that fight Brooke because that's I mean
we how do you feel man
yeah I was combing of in Madison Square
Garden part of you here's a huge fight
it's huge it's like exactly where things
were headed right and I took this fight
because it was it was like a fight for
my legacy it's Nate Diaz he's really hot
right now yeah coming off of two of the
biggest UFC pay-per-views ever but
before the Conor could beep and it was
just a crazy timing for this fight to
come together but it sucks I had to pull
out but you know I think that shows
maturity on my part you know when I was
younger I probably would have kept going
I would have said a word I wouldn't told
my manager the UFC that I was injured I
would have fought and then you know but
now I just got a look at it as a whole
I'm trying to be professional with this
you know I'm injured yeah
I can't run sprints I can't throw kicks
right now so yeah that's a big part of
my trailer that's huge Oh 100% man yeah
I was watching some of your fights this
past weekend and like yeah it's like
dude that kick and it's [ __ ] crazy
like how do you do that because you got
to pay attention to somebody's hands and
then they got their [ __ ] feet well
usually you don't want to throw you want
to put something in their face throw
punches or combinations or make them
think something else before you kick you
want to just throw dry kicks you know
yeah yeah now what is it dry kick mean
just I just called it dry kick just a
kick by itself usually want to set it up
with something like put some throw a
hand combination or just something to
distract him from the kick right yeah oh
I see what you're saying dude yeah watch
someone they had a fight that you had
done with this guy Cub Swanson member a
while back that dude look like he it
looked like he had like nine arms
brought that dude it seemed like it was
fighting like a and look at you were
fighting 40 raccoons that guy was just
it was like a he's like a tornado or
something yeah he's a vet man been
around a long time I grew up watching
that guy fight did you read yeah yeah
and WC you know would it be so is it
scarier if you grew up like watching a
guy or do you have any thoughts like
that when you go in like is there any is
it is there any like fear about the
actual guy or is there fear about the
the cage is there fear about this like
what is that kind of like when you go
into the fight uh there's not a lot of
fear it's just a lot of anxious energy
you know the unknown
but yeah anxious enter yeah just a lot
of anxious energy but but uh guy like
cub you know I take pride in fighting
those kind of guys like oh yeah guys I
grew up watching like him and Eddie
Alvarez my last fight oh yeah dude that
guy's a journeyman that guy's father
like 40 times he's like he has every
belt of every major organization and
he's now he's going to one Fc and
chasing another one geez but uh I take
pride in that and I'm happy with that
because like they say you know work
until idols become rivals and that's
where we're at now
you know I'm fighting these guys I've
thought man I used to go to Buffalo
while he's with my wife and be like well
my god we're watching this guy you know
now I'm in the cage with that shocking
so cool yeah
that's the same way I feel about comedy
it's like sometimes I like I'll be in a
green room and like Rogen's in there or
bill burrs in there and I'm like damn
dude this is crazy I'm like and they're
not looking at me like I'm a weird guy
or what the server yeah that's very easy
so how so like see you have this moment
now where you so you have to step aside
from this fight to make sure you're well
and then what like so does did you have
to talk to Diaz before that or how does
that kind of break down no I speak with
my management and then with the UFC
matchmakers and stuff like that yeah but
this is a quick a quick turnaround for
me if my body takes good to the stem
cells they're saying I'll be training in
three weeks oh wow
and and hopefully I'll be a lot less
pain and range of motion will be better
and we'll see but but I'm gonna you know
keep good energy and have a good mindset
about it I'm pretty sure it'll help me
out
yeah do you feel that so now with the
Diaz fight then be hopefully rescheduled
or to see go on to fight somebody else I
don't even know how that works it's
different in every in every case but I
saw um interviewed Dana White saying he
didn't want to rebook this fight but uh
if they do want to I'm open for it for
sure right so if they do want to rebook
it you'll just yeah for when we move it
to January whatever look exactly that
that's perfect right yeah damn January
get the holidays out of the way yeah my
birthday's January 19 so try to get it
in before that celebrate yeah man oh so
when you're at home right now like
what's that like I mean you got the
family life going on I saw you guys have
a beautiful little girl
Thanks she's beautiful man thank you my
mom and and you met your wife in
Louisiana yeah in middle school oh
really yeah yeah middle school man I
haven't looked there in a while thank
God
ah but uh and so you guys were just like
sweethearts huh yeah yeah been together
off and on all through middle school
through her high squashy was in high
school and then we got married you know
what 20 years old Wow yeah
dude that's so like Southie that's so
like like that's so like kind of
Louisiana that's so that area you're
from people do that man ah that's
awesome huh
yeah that was uh we were watching some
dolphins in Destin Florida that was
after this last fight we went on a
little vacation and did your daughter
know that you fight does she think you
wrestle like this you have any thoughts
she's put it together now man cuz like
when I leave the house she says dad
punch punch like she knows I'm going she
goes to the gym she hits the bag she
knows about it she puts on my MMA gloves
and boxing gloves and runs around the
house trying to hit me that she coach I
don't know if she can put it all
together but she knows I do something
with ass women yeah great so now with
the so with the Diaz thing man like so
you don't reach out you did you reach
out to him after was there any like
communication after did he say that he
was bummed out like he's talking [ __ ]
saying I'm faking an injury and stuff
like that but yeah people are gonna say
what they want you know fans and him and
whoever else but I have two tears in my
labrum like I can't fake this you know
this is really really painful right now
this was gonna be my 40th fight I've
never pulled out of a fight or miss
weight in my life and I'm not scared to
fight somebody come on yeah you're ready
to fight that's how I eat yeah yeah are
you or will you discipline you
disappointed that this happened of
course yeah this is a huge blow to like
what I had plans oh yeah no I was gonna
beat Diaz and then challenge for the
title beginning of next year sometime I
was hoping yeah but uh everything
happens for a reason man yeah a hundred
percent do you guys have so well this
will give you at least time like over
the Hollett like I guess over the
holidays then you'll be able to like
there'll be a lot of excitement probably
amongst your family like energy kind of
moving up towards the fight yeah and
it's you know I don't get to spend a lot
of time home I've been fighting so often
since we moved back to Louisiana that
I'm in the house a month two months and
we're back in Florida Wow to three
months and then you know so at least
I'll be home for the holidays most
likely and yeah I have a non-profit I'm
going to do something for Thanksgiving
and we're gonna make a donation to that
to do though yeah sorting your website
so
that's really awesome and you so yeah it
seems like a lot of that's part of your
store like you like you
you like like when you think about
helping people like is there a certain
group that you think about how open or
like where do you think like help is
needed when you think about that kind of
stuff
so my nonprofit is just like um whatever
we think at the moment that we can help
and make a difference in the in our
local community we do it so I thought
you guys were doing backpacks for kids
school supplies this year did we did
that after the last fight 500 backpacks
and school supplies for the whole school
whole middle school that me and my wife
went to actually Wow yes not a little
Dayton club over there and uh yeah but
uh now we just do whatever's happened in
the community and right now
Thanksgivings coming up and I'm back
home so we're gonna do full plates for
Lafayette is is the name of the thing
we're doing now and we're just gonna
have a pickup couple days before
Thanksgiving and I'm gonna have you from
Louisiana you know the plate lunch is oh
dude but I'm gonna have thousands I'm
gonna shoot for like three or four
thousand plate lunches filled with
Thanksgiving food and then people can
just come pick them up that's however
whoever needs it that's that's what
we're doing next cool man we're gonna
make a thousand dollar donation to that
it's incredible I appreciate them yeah
man I appreciate it too that's so pretty
being out here and I love that man yeah
I think there's a like and that's one
thing I miss about being like at home a
lot of times it's just like out here
everything is so like separated bro yeah
it is so it's just like everything's
like work out here and you don't get a
lot of feeling of like familiarity and
stuff like that you know yeah my wife
was just talking about the other day
when we got back home because I've only
been home for a week or you know and I
had to leave begin obviously to come
here but we went to the grocery store
and she was saying like how how nice
people are you know and like oh yeah
yeah it's just so different in like
Miami area or I'm sure out here I
haven't been here long enough but people
are just so quick quick you know and out
there back in Louisiana man it's it's
people want to know what's going on they
want to talk they want to help you out
yet it's the most relaxed yeah for the
most part what do you guys have planned
for the Halloween well my daughter's
finally old enough to to know what's
going on and dress up so we're gonna
bring around the neighborhood yeah yeah
yeah we were at home last Halloween so
she was only one years old Denman and do
you dress up like a fat like and you're
like fight stuff when you go to
Halloween no I don't do too much
dressing up yeah yeah just that's for
the kids yes for the kids I don't what
about when you were a kid what was
Halloween like when you
we actually got a question right here
this came in from this guy looks like
you already lost a fight is on the
youtuber not here but listen to this one
real quick
hey Dustin hey Theo big fans of both you
boys and I was just wondering if you had
any good Halloween stories or memories
that you'd like to share and what you're
gonna dress up as this year thank you
good luck to both you there you go
good timing yeah good timing man I uh
I'm not I'm not dressing up no I'm not
I'm not dressing now what if your
daughter wanted you to dress up when
she's old enough to ask me and and
really want me to then would that's a
different story
okay yeah what about the stories back in
the day I don't really do it I don't
never never dressed up not immediately
no I don't have any memories of that
really yeah yeah Wow but do you remember
like Halloween like when you're at
school won't stuff like that you know
they would not really yeah
but they do it over there huh for sure
big time yeah yeah I didn't go to a
whole lot of school honestly man really
yeah so did you like learn a lot at home
or what was going on there
oh yeah kind of I start starting trouble
in middle school um and when you say
trouble were you a five were you just
like fighting B yeah stuff like that
getting expelled from middle school for
fighting and stuff like that but I got
put in the alternative program and put
back in the right grade yeah and then I
went to ninth grade and then I got in a
bunch more trouble and did a little bit
of ninth grade in juvenile detention and
then I just didn't go back to school
so do you think like what caused all of
that cuz cuz you were probably there
dude then if I was at school with you
I'm like [ __ ] that guy's a [ __ ] dick
you know or that guy is like I'd be
scared of that guy nah we're kids like
words it just like a kind of a tough
environment or was it like you guys like
just like to fight or yeah I'm from
Northside Lafayette Louisiana it's a
tough area yeah but yeah I was just
always getting in trouble and scrapping
and doing things I should have been
doing yeah yeah
and school is what your thing no it
wasn't one thing you got out yeah damn
that's [ __ ] wild and that's back I
actually got a rest of her truancy from
not going to school you really yeah yeah
when in like eighth or ninth grade yeah
mmm cuz there was some point I remember
like after eighth grade first of all
like Oh like 70% of the black kids at
our school were
gone after eighth grade right like I
didn't know where any of them went right
if they weren't playing sports a lot of
them were out and then yeah and after
night a lot of kids left like in
Louisiana I don't even think about that
yeah a lot of kids just [ __ ] jet it
just start working you know yeah yeah or
just getting like especially if their
family had a job or something like that
what kind of work did you get into I did
cement work I did building decks
construction work and then I when I was
18 I got a decent job with the buildings
distribution company yeah and we would
go to job sites and like deliver doors
and just brand new houses so everything
they need trim doors windows I did that
for a couple years yeah and did in at
one point do you were like man this
isn't for me
I was fighting during those you already
fight yeah I was fighting when I was 18
but I did that and I had benefits at the
place so I didn't want to quit the job
cuz you know oh yeah with you yeah yeah
okay so yet its support that yeah yeah
but I was making like such little money
that I was just working because I needed
the benefits and I was fighting so yeah
you know damn I was still working I was
still working when I was fighting the WC
I think even in the UFC I was still
working with Zirin not wizard what was
that moment like we're like okay now at
least make hadn't have enough income
where I don't have to do a side job was
that that was huge part of my life yes I
was like I'm finally but you know people
run around and say they're professional
fighter but they don't really feeding
their family and paying their bills
being a professional fighter yeah yeah
they already yeah right it's like you
see kind of say you are for a long time
but until somebody sees you walking on a
real stage on television or something
it's just like but even then I was on
television I was still working you know
but when I got to finally walk away from
my work and commit a hundred percent to
fighting it was it was a you know felt
like the sky opened up and the Sun was
shining on me like we made it you know
we we really have a chance at the that's
crazy and the wildest thing about your
profession like at least you know and
it's so many professions you can kind of
be anywhere you know there's a billion
lawyers you know and there's a billion
you know there's and there's tens of
thousands of comedians but in your
profession there's only like it just
keeps getting smaller towards the top
until you have the strap right yeah man
there's you know lots of fighters
nowadays is such a popular sport yeah
and
it's not like we find out who the best
is you know we fight each other and find
out what the best is so that's a pretty
cool way to uh you know filtering out
everything yeah when you look back at
like a fight that you if you could have
a another fight or do one over it could
even be one that you won or it could be
one that you didn't do you have any that
pop in your head that you're like oh
that one um
one that sticks out for sure is the kind
of McGregor fight I just way too
emotional yeah I just cared too much
about everything going on and read too
much about what people thought and it
was he a celebrity at that point really
no not really I mean what he was right a
lot of people you had a lot of hyper on
him but he wasn't the guy years now you
know right yeah now it's almost like
he's uh yeah now he's more of a
celebrity or if you than a fighter or
not more than but it's like a long equal
yeah and it's different it's different
when people become that or I notice
anywhere I can stand up like Dave
Chappelle will come into the comedy club
and he's like a celebrity you know when
he gets onstage and he'll it mean he's a
funny guy but he's but if bill burr
comes in bill burr is a comedian like
bill bird does his [ __ ] job he
murders every time like Chappelle is a
little bit more like oh look at me we're
bill burr is like sneaks in does his
[ __ ] work really good and leaves you
know feel that um for the love of the
craft yeah yeah do you start to see that
in your in your line of work too like
some guys when they become celebrity
like it seems different
yeah people change for sure you start
making money people start running up to
him for autographs and they start
getting that you know recognition in
public and stuff people change for sure
yeah the ego is dangerous huh yeah man
do you worry about that
no cuz I'm in it for the scrap you know
yeah I try to walk away from that type
of stuff you know how right I think if I
see a bunch of guys wearing you have C
shirts up with the hoodie on and I kind
of turn you know yeah you just want to
win the belt yeah I just want to win the
belt man that's all I want I just want
to be the world champion and then I'll
go back to deliver in Windows okay so is
that is that really that goal I mean is
that so that's the thing that's the you
just want to be the best yeah of course
I would I would love to stay in the
sport for a long time and make a
shitload of money but I just want to say
that I did it I want to have the UFC
championship around my waist you know
all these years with my wife struggling
and and taking food out of the out of
the grocery basket because we couldn't
afford it and make an in
meet and and you know sacrificing a lot
I just want to say it was all worth it
because once you become the world
champion you know that's forever yeah
and you know that's that's what I'm
trying to do honestly Dan that's
powerful man it's really really cool
it's so inspirational
can you hear my crotch making a rustling
sound I can't either my crotch is dead
asleep right now that's because it's all
softened up in these me undies me undies
man it's like I just it's like just
tying a bunch of soft chubby babies
writer on your jump me undies are the
best underwear ever they're made from
micro mode ow fabric it's three times
softer than regular cotton you know
cotton that comes in the top of vitamins
it's three times softer than that me
undies has multiple fun prints and each
month they have matching socks and bra
let's so if your lady wants that bra let
you can get that bra let 100%
satisfaction going guaranteed you're
gonna love these underwears and they get
15% off your first pair and free
shipping and a 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to meet undies comm slash
weekend and I'm telling you right now my
crotch is locked up in me undies go to
meet undies dot-com / weekend for 15%
off your first pair it's a great gift
come on guys support the podcast thank
you very much this episode is brought to
you by Squarespace think have you ever
been in a space before what did it look
like do you remember could have been
square from websites and online stores
to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace Squarespace
it's that all-in-one platform to build a
beautiful online presence and run your
business look if you have a business and
it's just you're hoping people drive by
or stumble in are you hoping there's a
storm and everybody runs in to your
business to buy your product that might
happen but what's definitely gonna
happen is people are gonna see your
product online and Squarespace has that
all-in-one platform to create a
beautiful website domains websites
online stores marketing tools its
award-winning 24/7 customer
service that means if it's 4:00 a.m. do
you can wake up and get that assistance
you can head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com slash Theo
von to save 10% off your first purchase
of a website or domain that
squarespace.com slash Theo von to save
10% off Squarespace
did your wife work as well it's not
really any of our business but she
worked throughout my whole career and
then when we moved to Florida she was
actually in school in Louisiana she
followed my crazy ass dreams and pulled
out of school out of college and moved
with me to South Florida and then
started working a normal job and she
worked until she had the baby yeah
and did she come to the fights or
everyone-everyone dude my wife used to
me and her in Louisiana
I wrote a bicycle to work she we were
you we were both use her car she would
pick me up after she worked all day and
bring me to the gym huge she used to
drive me to like Lake Charles and these
Motel 6 dude gunshots and stuff and
outside she would be a crazy man she's
been my dog has she vent yeah she's been
she's she's an anchor bro
yeah I wouldn't for sure I wouldn't be
as far my career without her yeah yeah
and cuz what is that because there's a
you always have that home that home is
always there it is and you know just she
just balanced it balances me out man and
no telling what I would be doing you
know if I wasn't married all these years
I probably been cutting up and getting
trouble and not his focus oh yeah
definitely out is focused but I have a
we have a team me and my wife not sound
cheesy with this but we have a team and
we had goals that we set right and uh no
well look it's working bro yeah yeah no
it's a huge part of my my fighting
success my wife for sure yeah Nick you
have some yeah so going first of all I
want to thank you for especially the
Eddie Alvarez to and Joseph Duffy I want
a lot of money on you
you were almost a two-to-one underdog on
Joseph Duffy that was absurd but so
thank you but going back to that Connor
fight when you you were fighting at 145
like how much are you depleted fight
night do you feel fresh but and now
you're at 155 are you
fresh by fight night when you cut that
much way or does it have an effect on
your performance I'm sure it has some
some effect I don't feel it as much at
55 even though I'm cutting a lot of
weight to make 55 55 it's not easy
anymore this last fight with Eddie
Alvarez fight night I left the place I
was staying at to go to the arena was
178 so I put on 20 23 pounds I'm still
cutting a lot of weight but at 45 I felt
really really bad yeah and what is you
just feel like weak like there's not a
lot of water in your cells so you're
probably you kind of for me I maybe
people's symptoms are different I just
felt a little off-balance
I felt like foggy in the head yeah I
felt my muscles would get fatigued when
I when I would squeeze like I would just
a pump would come really quick and I
could it just weird feeling my whole
body felt a little flat-footed sometimes
yeah like I put the weight on and my
muscles didn't suck it up it was just
like in between my skin kind of it's a
weird feeling man foglia almost yeah
yeah do you have you noticed that you
are you like really in tune with your
body like can you kind of like because
you're constantly I mean your body is
your it's your occupation almost you're
I'm very into my body
yeah so you can kind of feel all the
time what's going on yeah yeah is it it
you are you more weary these days of
like pushing the envelope sometimes
because you know as you you know you're
29 now as you get older it's like yeah
it's like the years start to become
crucial you know in the last few years
I've noticed like when I was younger I
can train every day three times a day as
hard as I wanted to be fine wake up the
next day and do whatever but now like if
I have a hard sparring session I wear
that that you know bumps and bruises for
a couple days after that so my training
kind of like a bang over kind of dude
like a hangover but for fighting yeah
yeah exactly exactly yeah man like when
you were young you could drink every
night wake up and oh you start over
right yeah you do whatever you want if
you cut your [ __ ] leg off when you
were young different time yeah bangle
yeah so it so if this spike so after
this stem-cell stuff you'll know if
you're ready to rock again then yeah I
want to talk to the doctor again Tuesday
they said and then I'll go in Wednesday
morning but uh everybody reacts
differently to stem cells hopefully my
body reacts really well to it yeah and
you know it takes a lot of the pain away
and gives me back my range of motion
take some of the inflammation out but
I'll be back in three weeks to training
Wow yeah yeah I got stem cells just
really take your blood out and then take
the cells out of it and inject a menu
that's PRP oh that's PRP that's yeah I
got that in my hair yeah just to keep
this [ __ ] class going bro well master
well if I get hot I was down by y'all
might get hunted like [ __ ] Daniel
Boone dude it's kind of crazy when I go
outdoors in Louisiana if I'm out at
night bra and I turn around there be a
lot of raccoons what's the last time you
been Tiki to me what is it now that's
that's right around your area Denham
Springs area Oh Tiki - yeah what is that
when people would get to eat or Django
no no there's like just that would be
crazy
uh I don't know it's like I don't know
if it's a river or some stream that's
miles long people go up there with their
they have like oh no ice chests yeah
yeah and she floats down it's like a
slow look there you go take your tubing
Denham Springs oh yeah dude I've been I
thought you brought that mullet up there
atomically I was wrong there we went
with you we went in the boga Chitto
River right this is like which I'm going
over to River I honestly feel like it's
an outlet from a business I feel like it
should be definitely shut down like
condemned a number one time we're like
going and there's like this bend in the
river and this dude is out there with a
girl in there just shooting a gun into
the water right and they're on a date
it's like this goddess like that's
romantic bro yeah so we start coming
around this bin and we keep getting
closer and they're just still shooting
into the water you know this guy's
obviously trying to [ __ ] so I'm yelling
I'm like hey brother you guys stop
shooting the gun and the guy yelled back
he's like why because this is literally
like 20 it's gonna almost be like a game
you would see at a carnival where like
you know people are trying to get those
little ducks or whatever
[ __ ] idiots we ask Louise anima we
had to say minion in Wisconsin on the
Apple River and that was Wisconsin's
Mardi Gras basically their jet beads and
girls got wild and for some reason at
the end of the river there was always a
Jack Johnson cancer is really what do
you uh do what do you miss about growing
up in Louisiana like you miss anything
about being young or do you feel like
was that the best time your life is this
the best time your life
I mean they're both awesome yeah you
know we shall his family pretty close my
family was like my mother and her mom
and dad we were close there but my
family was kind of spread out yeah yeah
um like I kind of missed the UH the
innocence of beginning of my fight
career oh yeah yeah I kind of missed
that a little bit yeah yeah that was a
fun time of my life but growing up in
Louisiana was fun man you know picking
pecans and getting into trouble yeah
isn't it isn't it interesting that like
I start to think about that too like I
didn't realize that like the journey
part of it was like the crate was gonna
be the craziest part right you know now
it's a little bit more like business
it's still fun yeah you know even with
Connie you know like not to compare them
but it's still exciting like you know
the shows and the you know in the
preparation and the and doing the little
shows to get to the big shows right but
- yeah but the like I remember hanging
my groceries outside of like I was in
Kansas City one winter and I would buy
groceries and then hang them out of the
it was freezing outside so I'm hanging
out the window at night to [ __ ] keep
cold and then bring them in in the
morning it all out and then eat lunch
you know but it was like things like
that we're gonna be the best yeah yeah
for sure man like the straw journey
Browns yeah the journey yeah the
journeys kind of the wildest part right
but it's also fun for sure man yeah so
how many more fights you have to have to
get to get to the Bell
we'll see I mean I'm think I'm ranked
number three right now so it's khabib is
the champ then Tony Ferguson then Connor
than me yeah Connor just what could be
Tony probably is gonna if I could be
next
so I'm after that right yeah so now so
why was Diaz the fight that you got that
you got put into then if he's not in
those three he's ranked a 10 I believe
oh it was just a fun fight that I mean
sometimes you get the right matchups
that you know are gonna be a banger and
this one one of them you know I met his
brother one time Ryan I was doubt that
guy was wild enough man Nick Diaz yeah
yeah yeah man they got some like yeah
they're fighters man sure they're
fighters no doubt about it do you think
about when you go in now is it more
about like do you think about like you
prepare for the fighters weaknesses and
strengths or is because I'm watching
some fights when you were young and it
was almost like letting like a dog loose
from one side of the Ring you know right
like you know why when somebody's dog
weak it loses something with reading
coming at you yeah you can't do nothing
about the stream it was like ah because
I could do a screen watching it like
watching a car wreck yeah like damn this
car is just gonna keep on wrecking but
do you is there more strategy involved
now yeah this is uh it's definitely an
art now back in those days it was just
it was a fight and it still is a fight
but it's definitely more technical man
we break down footage my coaches do we
train specifically for certain guys and
that's one good thing about American Top
Team there's so many guys there yeah
they're like if I'm fighting the Diaz we
have tall guys who I can spar with uh we
have southpaw we have he's you know
obviously a really good jiu-jitsu
practitioner we have guys who are great
in jiu-jitsu a lot of black belts on the
mat so like all bases are covered when
you're at a big camp like that that's
one of the benefits that's one of the
values did uh did platinum Mike Perry
ever be down there I've never seen him
there and you haven't that guys Wow I
think you think he trains a lot in
northern part of Florida maybe yeah ok
yeah
is there any fighters out there that
like people don't know about that are
like you know like is the toughest guy
you've ever met is it is that been in
the cage or as I've been in the streets
you think uh I don't do any street fight
haven't been in a street altercation
maybe like the gym or something there's
incredible guys that you've never heard
of coming from all over man that I run
into in the gym that are you know for
hopefully they make a name for
themselves so get a break and get that
moment of spotlight where they show who
they are but there's lots of great
everybody who's in the UFC is made it
there and then they're incredible
fighters but there's so many guys out
there that haven't made it there yet or
that are fighting on smaller shows that
are just as good as a lot of these guys
yeah yeah dude do um so when you say
like get a break like what kind of break
has to kind of happen like do you have
to have a manager that gets you a fight
like how much of that kind of stuff goes
on behind that's a little bit of
politics of course but like beating the
right guys um maybe let's just say there
was a match maker for the UFC who's
watching this up-and-comer and you're
his opponent you go out there and beat
his ass not now the matchmakers are
looking at you like wow who's this kid
like that kind of break just the right
match
the right eyes on the fight Yeah right
the right platforms to really show who
you are yeah
but nowadays men there's so many
streaming organizations that are on
online and they have fight pass
oh yeah given all these guys a place to
fight where where a lot of eyes can see
it so there's a lot of more
opportunities now yeah yeah dude I
remember when I was they had this thing
for a while it was like gay dudes were
fighting at bars right and they would
set up like a ring or something and they
would have to Gators would fistfight and
uh and people would bet on it and [ __ ] I
remember that did I think that was yeah
when I was at LSU for a while well I
don't know what happened in that she
don't mind I got shut down it cockfights
yeah I think I think it was like really
triple-a you know do you think that you
could fight an animal ever but do you
think it's ever gonna get to that what I
like a bear all right yeah I don't know
like if you think like I thought like if
I can kangaroo with gloves on like if
you fight a couple body shot that thing
could you would you really yeah I mean I
don't I would can they kick what's the
rules
what is the rules yeah sometimes I just
wondered that like if you like if I was
a fighter right that's what I think
about like if I was a fighter you know
and I could fight and when then I would
stop thinking like oh when I quit
fighting people yeah and want to start
fighting animals
that's a Nate Diaz kangaroo is it yeah
pull up the Nate Diaz kangaroo
side-by-side that really was the one
yeah are you amazed sometimes how some
guys look like they could look like they
can't fight and they can totally fight
yeah that's one thing I learned early
like you know looks or you know if a guy
looks strong for the most look there you
go right oh wow that's wild they're
identical virtually identical yeah a lot
of times like you'll see a stringy lanky
guy not a lot of muscle definition and
then you get on the mat with the meat
guys incredibly strong you know or you
see a guy who's got huge muscles in and
you go with them you like this guy's not
really that strong yeah a lot of that's
for sure I mean most of the time a guy
looks big and strong he is but that's
like it doesn't transfer over to
grappling and fighting he might be able
to lift a lot more
wasting you but like functional
squeezing and and and technical stuff
it's not the same right yeah that's one
punch is still there like if a guy's
really big he's probably gonna have a
good shot yeah but uh it won't last long
and then the muscles don't translate
when you grapple what was like did you
have like a fit you have like a ever
have like a plan when you first started
to have like a finishing move you know
dude honestly I trained my whole career
just to finish any way I can which
strikes submissions
oh I never once game plan to go to the
judges or win round by round I just
fight I most of my fights have I've
never really had a solid game plan
really I don't like that yeah yes like
to fight it you like to fight I just
like to fight so for you it's like
you're just you get a feeling you're a
you are in a fight right so if the guy
kicks a lot we'd kind of prepare for
that but I'm not putting together crazy
stuff that that you know we just get
ready for a lot of kicks or if the guy
box as well we do a little bit extra
boxing but I don't I don't I know some
coaches go crazy with game plans like
we're gonna jab and then we're gonna put
him against the fence and take him down
and like I've never done that where I
just fight and hopefully opportunities
present themselves and I capitalized and
I kind of trust myself in combat I've
been like I said this is gonna be my
40th fight with Nick Diaz I've got a lot
of time in there you know in that right
in that yeah that huh yeah yeah is it
[ __ ] violent bro when they close that
[ __ ] up have you ever heard of much does
it make a sound when they close the cage
door oh yeah yeah it's metal oh look for
a trap I'm sure like the same thing when
you're on stage at a comedy show like
that all the lights are on you right so
that looks really dark yeah so it's like
that in the cage yeah it's really light
light up everything's lit up and you
kind of look at through the fence you
can't really see anything out that much
you know you see like the first Roble
yeah yeah it's really similar that's
crazy yeah so then you're just in there
you just and you can can you see to do
some guys is like can you tell when a
guy is lasered in and can you almost see
when you look in a dude's eyes in the
ring like can you feel if you think he's
been training hard if he's been focused
does all that kind of come into that
moment or is it still it's different for
everybody some guys are like that they
looking at you and they're really
intense and all that and you get and
then you whip their ass and then they
you know but some guys don't want to
make eye contact they're kind of staying
to themselves and then the bell rings
and they're maniacs trying to trying to
take you out right everybody's different
I think it's more of a personality and
personality thing when
you're fighting are you looking somebody
in the eyes or are you is it is it more
of this kind of this wider kind of view
that's going on yeah I mean eye contact
is made for sure but I'm kind of like
all my senses are engaged I'm just kind
of the whole picture I'm seeing yeah and
you at this point in your career are you
thinking or is a lot more of it like
Rhea is just natural it's a flow almost
you know it's just a flow the only times
I really start to think a lot is in
positions like against the fence if
we're both crunched up or like I get a
takedown and we're on top we have like
moments of clarity and there were things
kind of slow down I'm sorry [ __ ] I can
hear Joe Rogan talking right now he's
right there well but then it goes back
to the to the craziness I don't feel
like you have time to think you know
you're doing what you what you're
trained to do there's there's a little
tiny bit of thinking about it if I can
explain it to you think about this if
you're driving on the interstate right
and and and somebody slams the brakes
and you see red lights do you say I need
to hit my brakes not to know I know he's
too late you you know you don't have
time to think you just do it that's kind
of a fighting is the guy punch it I
don't say well there's the punch I'm
gonna slip it in counter you just do it
you know just like hitting the brake I
just do it I've done it so many times
it's muscle memory and my brain and it's
just what I do yeah yeah so do you feel
more comfortable in a fight than say
like like what's something you would
feel like uncomfortable in speaking in
front of a lot of people I guess would
probably be a big one
right um you brought I want once I'm
doing it I wouldn't probably have a
problem but the thought of doing it it's
like oh oh here we go
so you'd rather be in a fight than being
a public speaker yeah fighting absolute
last thing I would ever dude I'd rather
fist fight a kangaroo then then go do a
comedy show you don't tell you I'm
telling you what's next is gonna be a
league that travels around and it's
gonna be men fighting animals dude what
about 40 foxes you think you can fight
45 40 baker's dozen together oh let's
take another call that came in for sure
vo man brother I want to ask that I'm a
huge fan I live in Youngsville Louisiana
so not far from it one what's your
favorite place jet here in Alaska Darien
don't say no special boy and in second I
mean I know you have a diamond training
center but I was curious as to you know
I guess future business opportunities
that you were maybe looking into
establishing here in the last year area
post MMA career so killing it prep y'all
yeah man what's up what's up yeah dude I
live in Youngsville oh do you yeah yeah
I'm always at the rouses and I love
rouses no I did it's a spot do rouses
the best man yeah oh yeah roses does
everything and you think it's not gonna
be good when it first opened up I was
like this shit's all just gonna be like
but it's good that's good yeah I missed
it man and when I was in Florida for a
while and haven't been back to Louisiana
and then I fought in New Orleans and
there's that rouses right by the oh yeah
I'll do it was so awesome and to just
walk back in there and smell that smell
that crawfish in the air
yeah they got everything in there right
but I like praise Johnson Carencro I
like that spot but he's right Dino's as
good pizza man my buddy owns that place
I don't know what business ventures I'm
gonna have the diamond training center
but that's like I don't make money with
that that's just a gym a private gym I
have or local guys come we open the door
trained clean hats and just have fun
training oh but I really like beer maybe
I'll do something with some beer I I
don't know man we'll see I got a cool
idea for a TV show
oh yeah yeah yeah where I travel around
and train of gems and go to local places
to eat oh that's yeah yeah I got it up
here manage nobody does let me don't ya
wonder what it would be called man we
call food fight bro off the beaten path
places - yeah yeah like [ __ ] you got a
catch with your face to eat you know so
yeah 40 foxes bright we cutters turned
out so it's nice oh yes your idea - yeah
it should be all over everybody will man
fight the great idea actually I want to
do like so say I go to Louisiana we go
to a boxing gym then we go to some local
spot so we go to New Orleans I go to I
got a bunch of buddies who have gyms
like any gym in the US I gotta be able
to get in - yeah oh just because I've
been fighting so long and I know so many
people yeah but I'd like to do like
what's
that city like if I go to Philly we'll
go to a bunch of boxing gyms and we'll
hit a bunch of cool spots right and kind
of learn the gym story and then some
restaurants around there story
I like they know and what it's like what
at what guys that are training what MMA
guys are eating with UFC guys are eating
you know like well I'd like it to be
like not not so much the healthy stuff
uh-huh but like the local spots that
only these guys who live at this gym and
train there know about right like yeah
yeah to keep it grassroot yeah do you uh
is there a lot of pride from your area
dude there's a lot of support for you
dude and Crow it's amazing I mean you
know how Louisiana gets behind sporting
events or athletes do LSU or anything
that's one thing I can say about
Louisiana that missed me in a way is
like Louisiana supports Louisiana yeah
like like yeah yeah any if you're from
Lafayette everybody's behind you
everybody loves you um you know it's a
good feeling to have that sense of
community yeah yeah especially over
there where you guys are like my area is
more like just rural white kids like re
over just kind of white and black it was
you know we had some rednecks but we
didn't have a lot of like you know where
you guys are I feel like everything is a
[ __ ] recipe you know what I'm saying
like everything like if water floods in
the house then that soup you know it's
like it's just that kind of place for
sure yeah yeah and then family is like
and family's super important in
Louisiana that's another thing right
like people don't care like their dreams
and stuff are important but some
people's dream their whole dream is just
to spend time with their family yeah and
that's beautiful and in itself man yeah
but I think that's just a culture there
like in Lafayette the area I'm from is
Cajun country you know that's where all
the Acadians are oh yeah you know so
it's just a really good group of people
yeah yeah yeah man area that area is a
lot of fun and a lot of good people from
over there no doubt about a lot of good
food a lot of athletes - yeah for sure a
lot of great high school football you
know um yeah man I'm Miss Louisiana dude
I miss it I love Nashville - have you
been in Asheville never been a national
bar national is pretty cool yeah yeah it
doesn't have like the same kind of it's
more like kind of fancy South a little
bit but it has a I mean here some
[ __ ] just I mean it just still has
like a lot of like family first type of
stuff you know right that's why when I
get out here I'm just like I feel like
everybody I don't know family's not as
important you know yeah but I think it's
just as more of a city and it's as more
of a play
four people come to work it's business
is business yeah yeah his business out
here amazed it's not yet and laughs hey
I'll do that or Louisiana in general
like everybody's like I said supports
local but if you go into a bar and
there's Louisiana beer that's what
people are ordering and drinking yeah
there if there's a home homegrown
Louisiana food that's what their order
they want yeah it's just I like that
yeah do you uh do you feel do people
like do you get a lot of hard heads that
come at you because you're a fighter
that want to take on poor yeah I don't
put myself in those kind of positions
honestly I don't go to like bars really
and stuff like that's that much yeah
yeah probably out drinking is something
would happen a lot but that never
happened more on Twitter yeah a lot of
tough guys on Instagram on Twitter
that's why I can feel it idiot yeah
knuckleheads man that Vietnam not in
person never no never never Sam right
it's the worst was there ever an injury
that you like were you hit a guy were
you were like oh man this is like you
all my like you didn't feel like you
knew it was part of the fight but you're
like ah [ __ ] I feel bad about that no
never no no that's not it no it's not
part of it no it can't be right mm-hmm
so there's no room for that right
there's no room for that you know when I
get in there yeah I mean I'm that goes
back to like me saying I'm not looking
to ink out rounds and win a decision
when I get in there and the bell rings
yeah I'm trying to finish you or you're
gonna finish me it's like that's all it
is to it this is combat right you know
and how hard so how hard is it now to
have that patience to wait for that Diaz
fight to wait like you know cuz that's
like kidding that's it's just you know I
feel like it's it would just stress you
it is but I'm honestly a little proud of
myself man when I was younger that's
what it felt like the end of the world
oh my god this was such a huge fight
it's not coming together what what am I
gonna do Mike everything's falling apart
oh my god now I'm just like I just more
time yeah it's just everything happens
for a reason
if they want to fight it'll come back
together if and I will move on but we're
in a good spot and yeah there's only a
couple guys left you can fight right and
and just take it in stride man I'm gonna
get my I just want to not be in pain
yeah I just I just like I said I have
people depending on me and I need to
give myself the best shot at being a
world champion and to do that need to be
healthy and be able to Train like I need
to Train yeah so uh Cormier is from
Louisiana do you guys ever say my I
don't know really yeah yeah we talk all
the time
yeah he's a big I never met him he's big
I probably not much taller than me he's
round hey Fran yeah he's like an ottoman
you ever thought it you ever have an
ottoman you try to push our diamond over
and you can't really get it over I don't
talk about that oh yeah I feel like it
would be like a like three Ottomans it
was just like stacked on top of each
yeah man yeah is he a pretty cool guy
real cool
he seems really really good man does uh
do you talk to other guys like say like
you're gonna fight Diaz will you talk to
other guys that have fought him um if
there's somebody in my camp who's fought
him then we have talked but I don't go I
don't go like searching you know or
trying to find somebody's input yeah
yeah but if like like I said if there's
somebody at the gym who's fought him
they'll give me some input right right
um do you uh do you like when you're
envisioning it are you just thinking
about the fight do you like do you have
any like mental stuff where you like
envision like after the fight like do
you have any sort of like I guess stuff
for you kind of like go through things
in your head kind of or what some of
your procedure yeah you know fight week
I think I try to focus a lot on being in
the moment like tomorrow is gonna come
like you know Sunday after the fights
I'm gonna go home to my family
everything's gonna be okay but I just
need to focus on right now yeah not
yesterday not tomorrow I just need to be
right now in a moment be aware of
everything be okay with myself be just
it's a weird feeling but but I know how
I need to feel and I know my mind said
how it needs to be that's a huge part of
fighting his mindset it took me a long
time to realize that really yeah yes I
mean the biggest weapon you can have Wow
yeah and so you see it on some of the
younger guys now you're like oh I used
to be just like that all the time how
all that is that yeah all the time and
I'm like I'm just hearing stuff not not
only the way they act in practice but
some of the stuff they say yeah I got a
knucklehead yeah
yeah that's one thing it's it's kind of
interesting how you like as you get old
you get more up in your field or as you
spend more time in it yeah just looking
back you mean like man especially when
you said like I would have thought that
that would the end of the world and
everything what I can remember when I
was I lost the fight or got hurt in
practice or something didn't come
together though our sponsor fell through
the way I didn't think it was gonna come
in and like I thought it was the end
like I was like oh my god this is such
huge what am I gonna do this is matter
so much and man you know I'm a fighter
this is having a daughter has helped me
a lot put put things in perspective
really fighting is just something I do I
love it and I'm passionate about it and
I'm addicted to it and I want to be the
best in the world right at the end of
the day that's just fighting man right
I'm a father right and she has a life
and and I'm a husband and a son like
that stuff it took me a long time to
realize that but that stuff is and and
and looking at it this way
yeah caring less yeah you know caring
less about fighting I feel like I'm a
better fighter now yeah yeah oh that's
powerful man it took me a long time to
realize that man that's powerful stuff
and do you think some of that stuff is
just stuff that comes with age
yeah I'm Dustin Poirier fighting is just
something I do right right and in and I
know that now yeah yeah I'm a bad
[ __ ]
Wow imagine waking up in the morning and
being a bad [ __ ] I could never
imagine every morning never goes away
that's [ __ ] awesome dude [ __ ] you
don't want to fight Nick when you uh
after the fight is there something I was
thinking about this man like it's so
rare like in my life that I have things
physically that make me feel like alive
after a fight whether you win or lose I
was looking at some pictures of you
after if I want him yet I can like I
think you might have had a crotch or
something I mean I don't even know her
you were sitting on a table or something
just some couple different pictures and
I was like man and I couldn't tell if
you'd want to lost the fights right I
didn't even know which fight they were
from but I was just like [ __ ] he looks
so alive like there must be is there
something that just like to get to get
in front of well I guess any fight if
nobody's watching it's just so pure
combat one-on-one man that man just
you know fighting to the finish nobody's
jumping in it's just you you guys are
gonna handle this business and
somebody's gonna get beat up
yeah and that's so pure and like after
you go through that it's almost
spiritual you know after a fight it's
like almost spiritual like I just I'm I
elevated my life I walk away from fights
like I'm a different person I have a
different view of the world like it's
weird man it really is Akasaka and it's
a rush I can only get from that right
yeah when loser draw the next day I get
on that airplane to go home or to go
wherever we're going and I just feel
like I just went through a spiritual
journey you know and that's when loser
draw you feel that same kind of you have
that same moment and we're wow I went
you know winning is is obviously the
best thing it's like a trip or something
like you're tripping you can have a good
trip or a bad trip yeah obviously losing
is the bit you're on a bad trip right
but it's just that it's just a high that
you're on and you could only get it from
that and it's a crazy thing to do man I
could imagine it seems the air but
almost like taking a drug or something
and back in the day like I was saying
about innocence I kind of missed that
innocence there wasn't as much on the
line I was just fighting for the love of
fighting yeah there's bills on the line
and got to get home healthy to my
daughter none of that stuff was in my
mind as a young fighter yeah just you
know let's bleed yeah I know let's put
on a show damn for 500 bucks let's just
hope nobody died but now it's like so
much on the line every time I step in
there yeah
and they say spiritual yeah yeah it
seems like that it seems like it would
only be like a native but yeah it almost
seems like yeah it makes me wonder when
I look at that kind of stuff and I just
look at the pictures after I was like
man it seemed like no matter what I
couldn't tell if you won or lost or
whatever it was but what if yeah you
would learn something about yourself you
know yeah you you like they say
adversity introduces a man to himself
yeah so when you win you learned the
whole camp but when you lose you learn a
lot about who you are too well and you
know I've lost five times in my
professional career yeah what do you
learn man I mean we're there I feel like
every time I've lost I've made huge
adjustments and explored those reasons
I've lost and I've always learned from
it really yeah every time every single
time so you'll go back and even look at
like okay this specific moment or two
that contributed to the loss and you'll
learns and
and you'll become more aware
specifically of that you feel yeah hmm
and whether it was if it was a technical
thing I did wrong then I go back and
work on on ways to round that out and
make everything smoother not getting
that position again but uh sometimes
it's middle you know yeah yeah the kicks
pissed me off dude I don't like when
people kick that much I don't like dick
kicks really people do that no I mean
not supposed to but it happens really oh
yeah are the people out there they just
do it just that I know there's probably
people out there who do it to get a
breather you know oh yeah yeah you get
one warning right I can burn that [ __ ]
I'll burn that [ __ ] at the start of the
second it's like a free time out in
there okay let's run up and both kick
each other to the dick real fast and
take a break you know five-minute uh
five minute break now and there's no
timeouts or anything no of course not
yeah yes once the bell rings you go yeah
oh yeah you go and do you um is there
like a moment in the fight say if like a
fight goes five rounds right if it goes
through all of them huh is there a
remote like is there usually like kind
of a flow to a fight or is it different
every time
they're like if it goes five rounds like
if it there's definitely different
rhythms yeah in fights you know you kind
of know after me from fighting so long
and having so many fights like I know
how I'm feeling in the fight how we're
matching up what I'm doing what I need
to switch things like that but every
fights different man every fight is a
different damn with that between three
and five round fights are you pacing
yourself more in the five are you full
speed I think my last three or four
fights have all been five around
schedule four five and I fight the same
you know I I prepare differently I try
to get there a little bit lighter so I'm
not cutting as much weight so like the
fatigue doesn't set in over though you
know dehydration and stuff doesn't mess
me up if we do go four or five rounds
but I fight from bell-to-bell
whether it's three rounds of five when
you it's so it's different seeing you
like some of your more recent fights in
your beginning fights it's so different
do you notice that when you watch them
oh for sure a big time and I was a
maniac I was just throwing punches and
eyes closed when you're for the fences
yeah yeah ones like a watching almost a
kid and one is more like watching a man
do you notice that when you see him yeah
and I and it is that I grew up
in this sport so there's there's fights
of me being a kid and there's fights of
me being a professional fighter feeding
his family that's Wow yeah do we have
any more questions Nikki yeah there's a
couple more they're kind of silly but
let's take one and then I just have one
more question all right oh I had one
more actually is are there fights that
you've had that were like on a card but
they weren't like pro fights that on
your record like in Louisiana like just
in a bar in a cage so everywhere is
different um and I didn't know that till
I got out out of Louisiana in Florida
you have to have like they can't knee to
the head and you can't well kind of
weird you have to have bigger gloves and
you have to wear shin pads if you're an
amateur so I have nine fights in
Louisiana that aren't on my pro record
that are pro fights well I'm not right
yeah the same rules yeah small gloves
knees you know some of them were you
allowed to elbow so I those just aren't
on my record
yeah and took two like and I've never
really been out of Louisiana but until I
started traveling for fighting really
yeah so getting on a plane to go fight
somebody okay yeah first time on a plane
is pretty crazy you know it's like the
military it's like Vietnam I was like a
lot of people first time they got on a
plane was is to go fight somebody
but yeah here's our last question then
so for those that are only listening he
asked with the greatest fighter of all
time Artem lobe off coming up fighting
next weekend how does Dustin think you
would do against him do you want to give
a little background on the goat artim
Lobo is a one economy Jewish training
partners I'm looking forward to watching
him fight man how would I matchup
against him I would stop but uh who do
you like to watch fight I like to watch
fighters fighters guys like Nate Diaz I
like watching him fight his about his
brother um Nick Diaz yeah like yeah I
like watching both of them Eddie Alvarez
you know just just engage you something
some of the guys that have fought or
really fun guys that's that
why I take those fights so guys who I
like to watch fight it excites me that's
the kind of fights I want to be part of
so that's why I fight a lot those guys
yeah they do so now how many fights will
you get presented that you will be and
you might be like not for me it happens
a good bit probably then guys I want to
take a shot at you not as much as you
think really yeah it's not like they
send me a list of five names and say
here's a here to pick a guy yeah it's
just kind of comes together at times
right you know like hey this guy it
seems like it's a decent matchup and
he's gonna be willing to fight it just
comes down to timing he wants to fight
this month you said you'll be ready to
fight this month you want to do this yes
or no that kind of that thing well I
like I have a choice that that often but
our acts for certain people yeah and
then that's when they make it happen and
you used to say if some come in will you
like do you decide immediately usually
what's your process do you kind of take
a beat when they call me with a fight I
call my coaches I say hey what do you
think about this matchup and then we
take a fight yeah yeah I've never turned
down one you haven't no wow pretty
fascinating you get this they got that
Cormier Lewis fight coming up yeah the
black beast sounds crazy I think they're
gonna let these guys dude and they're
Daniel they're both taking it pretty
pretty quick you know yeah Louis just
fought and Daniel was about two months
ago that most yeah yeah does um what
what happens in that what is a negative
about taking a fight quickly the good
thing is these guys are heavyweights so
they're not gonna be far out you know
they they can weigh whatever up to 265
pounds so that they're not gonna have to
cut weight for me would be a scramble
because I'm obviously gonna be a lot
heavier then I would be after a whole
training camp so I have a lot of weight
to cut you got to go in and cut it oh
yeah he'll be really bad you know but
you don't get time to train for the
opponent yeah you know you don't get a
lot of those sparring rounds and a lot
of mat time that preparing for a
specific style there's lots of downfalls
to taking short fights like that what do
you see happening in the in the Louis
cornea fight I think Daniels gonna take
him down I'm he's not gonna take the
risk of throwing punches with the real
heavyweight you know Daniels a big guy
but Lewis is a lot bigger yeah
and he's known for knocking people out I
think Daniels gonna wrestle him yeah
yeah so if you got a guy that's hunter
knock yo you got a you got to slow him
down usually then
yeah or you can break it down and try to
counterpunch him and there's I mean
there's so many things you can do
were you right-handed or left-handed
when you were a kid right in and are you
both handed now yeah I use both hands
for different things but I fight
left-handed oh really yeah [ __ ] that's
crazy dog I realize like if I'm I
noticed it it's a formal like do like
hopscotch I start on my left foot yeah I
noticed that yeah I can go right but
mostly I'm more laughs yeah yeah this
one had that many athletic skill like a
sprint you would start with you if a
sprint I think I would start
I wouldn't sprint anymore yeah me
neither my hip if so the stem cells
you'll know in three weeks then well I
think I'll know before they said I'll be
able to go back to training in three
weeks I don't know before then I don't
know how I'm feeling like in within a
week of the shots right yeah they're
also doing synovial fluid so my joint is
gonna be you know lubricating okay you
know oil change that's it huh yeah so do
it and that's just now do you just
really need enough to be able to get to
that fight is that kind of how you think
about it well they told me uh I mean
yeah as long as I can have a healthy
training camp and then fight whatever
happens after that just happens that's
kind of my mindset but I want to do the
right things and they told me that this
could be anywhere from eight months
relief yeah to a year and a half it's
hard to tell everybody's different okay
so this is kind of like I remember I got
a part of my dish take it out once and
they give you like the same thing they
give women when they're pregnant they
give a mom
epidurals right and so that would make
it so then totally like my back would be
fine for like six to eight months and
then it would it would just get kind of
bad again but maybe it's similar this is
a little bit different I think I don't
yeah maybe it's not even similar let's
take one more question man and then
we'll shut it down Eric Cohen from
Denver Colorado and that's why you got a
that bad boy the diamonds on yo show and
I got a question for him sorry I'm
talking kind of faster than doing some
cocaine yeah my question is uh what was
the craziest street fight he's ever seen
or been a part of in a few I think I
know yours is when you got out of when
you ran into the head-butting champ and
it didn't go your
but a CEO say carrying the whole time
stop doing on cocaine since a man I
haven't been part of a street fight and
to answer that question having part of a
street fighting I don't know how long
yeah I don't want to do that I don't
want to that's all I'm off the clock
yeah yeah did you ever see Anita have
you ever seen some real wild ones dude
last one that I could think of that I've
been in mm-hmm was one Mardi Gras down
in Lafayette Louisiana I was at my
brother's house and it was like a street
party you know the holster everybody's
out on the street and my wife was
leaning over a fence talking to somebody
and then guys from next door came over
and like bent over her back while she
was bending over and put his hand on her
stomach and like started talking in her
ear and then uh bro you just saw red huh
yeah I ripped him off I had a buddy of
mine who fights he started dropping this
other guy's people left and right
dude I mean dude 100% every shot that
landed everybody fell he shot a hundred
percent from the field that night then I
started punching this guy and then he he
had a lot more friends than we did and
my brother is not a fighter so he didn't
run it he didn't run out of the house to
come fight but it was just like people
were fighting every and yeah and I ended
up getting my back up against a car cuz
they were jumping yeah I was like yeah
and I got hit with a bunch of uppercuts
it was crazy man Mardi Gras Mardi Gras
things mighta got fun now yeah yeah
anything can happen in Mardi Gras day
yeah I love that dude my buddy uh some
guys slept in his truck all night one
year my something a portal at one time
in New Orleans man I don't have a place
yeah oh yeah I mean this is sita's damn
but yeah that's like the ritz-carlton
compared to where some people sleep out
there it gets a little deep out there
man
good I love that's one thing I do miss
about Mardi Gras man everybody would
drink all day and anything could happen
yeah you can start a family you could
start a fire to the family you can start
a fight anything could happen in Mardi
Gras man you'd end up with all kind of
strange people yeah I'll miss that stuff
man I think somewhat I miss really is
just being young you know and not having
those responsibilities like did armor
when I was young I would taken you could
take a nap and if you like you didn't
care how long it was you
set an alarm like [ __ ] bra yeah I'm
gonna sleep I might wake up tomorrow
don't even matter yeah it don't even
matter and now it's just like everything
is more just uh I guess adult you know
but I guess that's part of growing up
well man we wish you the best of luck
dude thank you so much for coming in bro
us is really really cool thanks for
having me yeah man wish you the best of
luck man we're gonna try and come out
and see one of those fights that'd be
dope man if you ever back in Louisiana
any time soon dude hit me up yeah and I
show you a good time
yeah and weed some boudin crackling dude
I'll come over there and do something
bro so I'm starting I'm saying dude I'll
eat some [ __ ] fire I'll bring some
Fox meat you know fight some kangaroos
well they had a couple brothers to live
by me when I was in Baton Rouge were
always grilling dove outside of my part
though yeah and there I go out there
dating these two black dudes is always
cooking dove dude and I don't usually
eat peaceful birds you know all right
but then one day I was like I'll [ __ ]
have some man and it was a good keep it
the violent birds most the time oh dude
I'll [ __ ] a toucan up you know some
toucan kebabs forget about it
Dustin Poirier the diamond best of luck
in this out come and fight man I hope
you heal up soon and we'll see you next
time thanks brother yeah
[Music]
it's gonna take
[Music]
well thanks for watching that video
right here that was a beautiful little
segment I think but of course i'm
partisan to myself but you can move on
to another video right now you can check
on this video or on this video that's
two different options and you can also
subscribe to the channel check on a new
video subscribe to the channel check
subscribe subscribe